[Applause]
let's get this out of the way I'm here
because I wrote a book about civility
and because that book came out right
around the 2016 American presidential
election
I started getting lots of invitations to
come and talk about civility and why we
need more of it in American politics so
great the only problem was that I'd
written that book about civility because
I was convinced that civility is
[ __ ] now that may sound like a
highly uncivil thing to say and lucky
for you and for my publisher I did
eventually come to change my mind in the
course of writing that book and studying
the long history of civility and
religious tolerance in the 17th century
I came to discover that there is a
virtue of civility and far from being
[ __ ] it's actually absolutely
essential especially for tolerant
societies so societies like this one
that promised not only to protect
diversity but also the heated and
sometimes even hateful disagreements
that that diversity inspires you see the
thing about disagreement is that there
is a reason that disagreeable is a
synonym for unpleasant as the English
philosopher Thomas Hobbes pointed out
all the way back in 1642 that's because
the mere act of disagreement is
offensive and Hobbes is still right it
works like this
so if you and I disagree and I'm right
because I always am how am I to make
sense of the fact that you are so very
very wrong it couldn't possibly be that
you've just come to a different
conclusion in good faith no you must be
up to something you must be stupid
bigoted interested maybe you're insane
and the same goes the other way right so
the mere fact of your disagreeing with
me is implicitly an insult not only to
my views but to my intelligence too and
things only get worse when the
disagreements at stake are the ones that
we somehow consider to be fundamental
whether to our world views or to our
identities you know the kinds of
disagreement I mean one doesn't discuss
religion or politics or increasingly the
politics of popular culture at the
dinner table because these are the
disagreements these are the things that
people really seriously disagree about
and they define themselves against their
opponents in the controversy but of
course those disagreements those
fundamental disagreements are precisely
the ones that tolerant societies like
the United States proposed to tolerate
which perhaps explains why historically
at least tolerant societies haven't been
the happy clappy communities of
difference that you sometimes hear about
know they tend to be places where people
have to hold their noses and rub along
together despite their mutual contempt
that's what I learned from studying
religious tolerance in early modern
England in America and I also learned
that the virtue that makes that unrest
coexistence if you will possible is the
virtue of civility because civility
makes our disagreements tolerable so
that we can share a life together even
if we don't share a face religious
political or otherwise still I couldn't
help but notice that when most people
talk about civility today and boy do
they talk about civility a lot they seem
to have something else in mind
so if civility is the virtue that makes
it possible to tolerate disagreement so
that we can actually engage with our
opponents talking about civility seems
to be mainly a strategy of disengagement
it's a little bit like threatening to
take your ball and go home when the game
isn't going your way because the funny
thing about in
ability it's always the sin of our
opponents it's funny when it comes to
our own bad behavior well we seem to
develop sudden onset amnesia or we can
always justify it as an appropriate
response to the latest outrage from our
opponents so how can I be civil to
someone who is set out to destroy
everything I stand for right and by the
way they started it it's all
terrifically convenient also convenient
is the fact that most of today's big
civility talkers tend to be quite vague
in fuzzy when it comes to what they
think civility actually entails
we're told that civility is simply a
synonym for respect for good manners for
politeness but at the same time it's
clear that to accuse someone of
incivility is much much worse than
calling them impolite because to be
uncivil is to be potentially intolerable
in a way that merely being rude isn't so
to call someone uncivil to accuse them
of incivility is a way of communicating
that they are somehow beyond the pale
that they're not worth engaging with at
all so here's the thing civility isn't
[ __ ] it's precious because it's the
virtue that makes fundamental
disagreement not only possible but even
sometimes occasionally productive it's
precious but it's also really really
difficult
civility talk on the other hand well
that's really easy really easy and it
also is almost always complete [ __ ]
which makes things slightly awkward for
me as I continue to talk to you about
civility anyway um we tend to forget it
but politicians and intellectuals have
been warning us for decades now that the
United States is facing a crisis of
civility and they tended to blame that
crisis on technological developments on
things like cable TV
talk radio social media but any
historian will tell you that there never
was a golden age of disagreement let
alone good feelings not in American
politics in my book though I argue that
the first modern crisis of civility
actually began about 500 years ago when
a certain professor of theology named
Martin Luther took advantage of a recent
advancement in communications technology
the printing press to call the Pope the
Antichrist and thus inadvertently
launched the Protestant Reformation so
think of the press if you will as the
Twitter of the 16th century and Martin
Luther as the original troll and I'm not
exaggerating here he once declared
himself unable to pray without at the
same time cursing his anti-christian I
eat Catholic opponents and of course
those Catholic opponents clutch their
pearls and called for civility than to
but all the while they gave as good as
they got with traditional slurs like
heretic and worst of all Protestant
which began in the 16th century as an
insult
the thing about civility talk then as
now was that you know you could call out
your opponent for going low and then
take advantage of the moral high ground
to go as low or lower because calling
for civility sets up the speaker as a
model of decorum while implicitly subtly
stigmatizing anyone with the temerity to
disagree as uncivil and so civility talk
in the 17th century becomes a really
effective way for members of the
religious establishment to silence
suppress exclude dissenters outside of
the established church especially when
they spoke out against the status quo so
Anglican ministers could lecture
atheists on the offensiveness of their
discourse everyone could complain about
the Quakers for refusing to defend on
their hats or their uncouth practice of
shaking hands but those accusations of
incivility pretty soon became pretext
for persecution so far so familiar right
we see that strategy again and again
it's you
- silent civil rights protesters in the
20th century and I think it explains why
partisans on both sides of the aisle
keep reaching for this frankly
antiquated early modern language of
civility precisely when they want to
communicate that certain people in
certain views are beyond the pale but
they want to save themselves the trouble
of actually making an argument so no
wonder skeptics like me tend to roll our
eyes when the calls for conversational
virtue begin because instead of healing
our social and political divisions it
seems like so much civility talk is
actually making the problem worse it's
saving us the trouble of actually
speaking to each other allowing us to
speak past each other or at each other
while signaling our superior virtue and
letting the audience know which side
we're on and given this I think one
might be forgiven as I did for assuming
that because so much civility talk is
[ __ ] well then the virtue of
civility must be [ __ ] - but here
again I think a little historical
perspective goes a long way as remember
the same early modern crisis of civility
that launched the Reformation also gave
birth to tolerant societies places like
Rhode Island Pennsylvania and indeed
eventually the United States places that
at least aspired to protect disagreement
as well as diversity and what made that
possible was the virtue of civility what
made disagreement tolerable what mate
what made it possible for us to share a
life even when we didn't share a faith
was a virtue but one I think that is
perhaps less aspirational and a lot more
confrontational than the one that people
who talk about civility a lot today tend
to have in mind so I like to call that
virtue mere civility you may know it as
the virtue that allows us to get through
our relations with an ex-spouse or a bad
neighbor not to mention a member of the
other party because to be merely civil
is to meet a low bar grudgingly
and that again makes sense because
civility is a virtue that's meant to
help us disagree and as Hobbs told us
all those centuries ago disagreeable
means unpleasant for a reason but if it
isn't [ __ ]
what exactly is civility or mere
civility what does it require well to
start it is not and cannot be the same
thing as being respectful or polite
because we need civility precisely when
we're dealing with those people that we
find it the most difficult or maybe even
impossible to respect similarly being
civil can't be the same as being nice
because being nice means not telling
people what you really think about them
or they're wrong wrong views know being
civil means speaking your mind but to
your opponent's face not behind her back
right being merely civil means not
pulling our punches but at the same time
it means maybe not landing all those
punches all at once because the point of
mere civility is to allow us to disagree
to disagree fundamentally but to do so
without denying or destroying the
possibility of a common life tomorrow
with the people that we think are
standing in our way today and in that
sense I think civility is actually
closely related to another virtue at the
virtue of courage so mere civility is
having the courage to make yourself
disagreeable and to stay that way but to
do so while staying in the room and
staying present to your opponents and it
also means that sometimes calling
[ __ ] on people's civility talk is
really the only civil thing to do at
least that's what I think but look if
I've learned anything from studying the
long history of religious tolerance in
the 17th century it says if you're
talking about civility as a way to avoid
an argument to ISIL
plate yourself in the more agreeable
company of the like-minded who already
agree with you
if you find yourself never actually
speaking to anyone who really truly
fundamentally disagrees with you well
you're doing civility wrong thank you
[Applause]
[Music]